think 2024 IBM Cloud reservations and
verd dantics green quadrant all on this
episode of IBM Tech now what's up y'all
my name is Ian and I am back to bring
you the latest and greatest news and
announcements about IBM technology even
though Larry David would argue that it's
too late to do so I want to wish
everyone a Happy New Year and say that
we're thrilled to be back with you on
IBM Tech now to kick off the first
episode of the New Year we're looking
ahead to think 2024 which is is taking
place from May 20th to 23rd in Boston if
you've never been think is IBM's annual
conference and this year promises to be
a unique and engaging experience that
will guide you on your AI for business
Journey no matter where you are on the
road from building AI Readiness with a
thoughtful hybrid Cloud approach to
scaling AI across core business
functions and Industry needs to
embedding AI into the heart of your
Enterprise strategy you'll hear best
practices see them come to life and
connect with the technology experts and
business Pioneers to help you succeed at
think 2024 you'll be able to hear
directly from IPM clients and ecosystem
Partners about best practices for AI
Readiness and scalability go deep into
immersive experiences to see how an open
trusted targeted and empowered Ai and
hybrid Cloud Foundation leads to scale
across core business functions in
Industry needs and begin building your
blueprint to becoming a company that
leads with AI for maximum Roi
registration is open now so click the
link in the description of this video to
learn more about think
2024 next up as organizations work to
reduce spending within Enterprise Cloud
environments they often face the
challenge of one-size fits-all payment
options through their Cloud providers
that's why we're excited to introduce
IBM Cloud reservations on IBM Cloud
virtual servers for VPC which can help
minimize spending risk throughout the
year and create more predictable
budgeting environments with IBM Cloud
reservations you can reserve virtual
servers in a specific IBM Cloud
availability Zone and data center and
enjoy the benefits these include locked
in cost efficiency through your one or
threeyear term improv budgeting and
forecasting with consistent monthly
payments guaranteed capacity and
availability of your virtual server
flexibility in provisioning and fast
deployment in minutes to learn more
about IBM Cloud reservations on IBM
Cloud virtual servers for VPC hit the
link below to wrap things up today we're
thrilled to announce that banxs has once
again named IBM and invisi ESG Suite as
a market leader in their report entitled
green quadrant Enterprise carbon
management software
2023 IBM stands out as the first of only
three vendors whose ability to leverage
AI is highlighted in the report invis
earned the highest scores for its data
acquisition data management and data
aggregation within vertic capability
Dimension the report highlights the
growing market for carbon management
software driven by organization's
voluntary and Regulatory commitments in
this evolving landscape the IBM Andis
ESG Suite empowers companies around the
world to address their greenhouse gas
data capture calculation and Analysis
needs and to streamline the reporting
and disclosure requirements to learn
more and read the report hit the link
below thanks so much for joining me
today for this episode of IBM Tech now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics I've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video and again please don't
forget to subscribe to our channel to
stay up toate on what's going on in Tech
now